welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down our big predictions for
the rest of invincible season 2 I want
to get straight into it as there's a lot
to talk about but obviously this will
cover major aspects of the comics which
will probably ruin the series for you
though it's never a one for one
adaptation it's still pretty close so
please turn off now if you don't want to
be spoiled I'm being nice today anyway
without the way huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into
Invincible season
[Music]
okay so the first part ended with a full
circle Arc in which Mark was once more
laid flat out on his back with a Vite
towering over him this time though it
was General Craig who was demanding that
he works with them yikes Craig is going
to play his part down the line but I
actually don't think he'll be the major
villain for the rest of season 2 unless
they massively Jump Ahead he's not
really also a major villain either he
kind kind of is but he's one of the sort
of buildup vilter mits to get into that
big bad who we won't SP spoil either
instead I think what we're going to get
is a big focus on angstrom Levy which
will bring things full circle from the
opening of the Season we watched his
origin story during episode one and I
think that by episode 8 we'll see the
character's downfall now how this
happens in the comics is that Mar gets
stranded on trxa after the Vite Invasion
spending a couple of months there he
helps to rebuild the planet and also
gets to know a stepmother and brother a
little better this point his brother
doesn't have a name because the thrax
believe that one should choose their own
name when they get to a certain age
eventually Oliver gets that one because
it's Debbie's father's name and it sort
of brings those two characters together
anyway on thraxa the civilization build
Mark a ship so he can fly back home and
he's entrusted with Oliver due to his
lifespan Andressa says that she'll be
dead by the time he can form a sentence
and that no one on the planet will be
there to care for him but he takes him
back to Earth and at this point Debbie
agrees to raise him now this is kind of
a big deal for her as he's of course
Nolan's son with with his other wife
Awkward episode 4 of season 2 had the
pair contemplating ending at all and
they had really Fallen mentally after
the events of the season one finale huge
shout out to brain pilot for poting out
that Nolan drifting towards that black
hole was because he wanted to end it all
and that that's one of the only things
powerful enough that can kill a Vite
still though he managed to find a new
life and in many ways O's a second
chance for Debbie OE kind of represents
a connection to Nolan as well and he
helps to fill the void that she's been
missing in her life eventually he calls
Mark brother like some Hulk Hulk and
and starts to get cheated by a
woman named April Housman now she's been
properly trying to deal with soup kids
so it's not too bad and it allows OE to
quickly learn about Earth and get up to
speed with everything I don't think that
olly will get to his kid omn man phase
in season 2 as it's still a long way
away story-wise but you never know with
this stuff like when I was flicking
through the omnus at this point it's
when Rudy gets put into his real Body by
the mes which happened in season 1 so so
you can kind of see how Stuff moves
about I also think that the seid
invasion will be happening in the
upcoming season as all that stuff with
shape Smith's been moved forward to it's
clearly been done for a reason and it's
a very big battle in the comic that
leads to a number of major things
happening but one of those most notable
things is that Mark fights in his blue
and black costume this is suat being
getting teased towards with the logo for
season 2 with the colors cracking away
to change things up I think that
signifies that it's coming and that the
seids will also arrive
now during part two I think that the
immortal in K will end up getting
married however this somewhat has a bit
of tragedy to it when the seids arrives
Cecil ends up sending the strongest
Guardians out because the creatures
won't be able to penetrate their skin
the Guardians like Kate remain behind
but it's at this moment that the lizard
League attack as well Kate is seemingly
killed during this by kimodo with all of
her duplicate bodies being brutally
murdered a funeral is held and it's a
pretty devastating way that I think they
could take season 2 turns out that the
Kate we've been seeing isn't the
original and though there's one two
three and and five is it number five
comes after I don't know I'm a YouTuber
there's still zero who's still the
original that all the other Kates
spawned from Zero's kept herself secret
from everyone and locked herself away so
that even if the other versions die
she'll still be alive in the end both
she and the immortal decide to retire
and start a family which may be
something they do down the line but I
don't want to get too deep into the
season 7 predictions or whatever either
way we had the list league and seids
getting massively teased in the first
part of season 2 so I think that's all
setting things for what's to come with
them both attacking at the same time the
Mark isn't going to have it easy dealing
with all that and on top of it he's also
really going to struggle with his
personal life too these next two points
kind of intertwine with one another but
just a quick word from our sponsors and
then we'll get the ball rolling now for
this video we've teamed up with exter
who get you better gear for life on the
move at the moment they're running a big
Black Friday sale and then one for
cyberweek next week where in both
they're giving away 50% off and an extra
5% off by using our code below now in
case you don't know extra seller range
your wallets bags and cases and
accessories to help your life on the go
right here I've got the poly wallet it's
minimalistic really Compact and it's got
this trigger function as well that makes
all your cards pop out every single time
they pop out that looks cool I
absolutely love doing that it just keeps
things nice and tidy you look smart and
I think this is a really good product
that I definitely recommend you pick up
this gray is the parliament wallet but
they've also got smaller ones as well
where it's just your card so you can pop
in and out and yeah really makes life
easy they've got an extra pocket for
cards in cash yet they can hold up to 12
cards and on top of this they're extra
secure it also blocks RFID Wireless
theft and comes in a range of colors so
no matter your luck you're going to look
amazing on top of this an extra that I
really love is the wallet tracker card
they've got a worldwide lost and found
Network so no matter where you leave it
you can instantly track it down and off
just 3 hours of solid charging it can
last for a full 2 months all you have to
do is just leave this in the Sun for 3
hours you've got two months of coverage
so you never need to worry about it it's
also credit card size voice activated by
using Siri Google or Alexa and it also
fits snugly into this and straps onto
your wallet boom nice and easy and yeah
you've got it on the go this is the one
I've mainly been using at the moment cuz
it goes with a suit you know I've been
got a lots of wedding recently uh so I
really love that but I also picked up
the black one as well cuz I like to mix
a match I like I said they've got a
massive Black Friday sale on at the
moment another one during cyber week and
in both you're going to get 50% off by
visiting the website but on top of that
an extra 5% by using my code and
clicking the link below my code is heavy
spoilers I'm sure you can guess it heavy
spoilers just click the link in the
description use that code and you're
going to get up to 55% off makes an
amazing gift I absolutely love this so
whether someone's birthdays coming up
you know Christmas is right around the
corner and you want to get shopping
definitely pick one of these up nice
safe and Ure very sliek and smart and
yeah huge shout out to them for
sponsoring the video thank you okay so
Mark's obviously been away for a long
time and due to how he left things off
with Amber she's been worried sick
completely unaware of what's been going
on with his personal life she spent the
weeks he's been away fearing for the
worst now though the pair get back
together there's still clearly the
realization in both of them that they're
not really cut out for this life that
they try and make it work Mark starts to
realize things aren't really meant to be
which we'll talk more about in just a
bit either way he flies out to Eve to
discuss it and at her Treehouse the pair
talk things over Amber is there and
though Eve says she's just a normal
human and isn't really cut out for this
Mark still holds out hope due to the
fact that she looks up this is because
at the start of the comics when the peir
got changed behind the dumpsters at
school Mark was worried that they might
get spotted however Eve said that normal
people never look up and th they were
okay Amber looks up at this point though
and Mark gets a bit more hope that she's
different now at this point Mark gets a
call from his home and he races back
there to discover angstrom Levy holding
both his mother and brother hostage it's
a big Cliffhanger that I think they'll
probably end an episode on as that's how
they do it in the source material with
them then taking us into issue 33 now
angstrom torns Mark and eventually he
sends him through several multiversal
portals that strand him out in alternate
realities his plan is to wear him down
and keep warping him back to beat the
crap out of him and then taunt him
further basically he dumps him into a
world and then pulls him out before
smacking him about and then sending him
into another now in the lead up to
season 2 there were lots of few times
that Spider-Man might appear in the show
in some form or another Shon as Simon
rasio PTI this during interviews for
part one with him saying people were
going to have to wait and see now both
Spider-Man Invincible are owned by Sony
so there is the possibility that the
pair could end up meeting at some point
in the comic Marcus send hurtling into
the back of Doc Ark and you can see
Spider-Man's hand just by the portal as
he flies out of it we can also catch a
web line so they may push things beyond
that and add it into the moment down the
line they also had a massive crossover
issue so they might just pull elements
of that across to give us a bit more
than what we get in the comics these
alternate worlds can add a lot of cool
little Easter eggs into the show as we
have so many things happening in them
that give nods to other Comics there's
also a zombie reality as well which
could be used as a way for Kirkman a
shout out his series The Walking Dead
I'd love to see Rick or something in
there too as at this point when the
Invincible comic was being met made The
Walking Dead was just getting started I
think Invincible started in 2003 with
The Walking Dead in ' 04 so I think by
the time we got to issue 33 in the book
we would have been we would have been
deep into that but I don't think that it
was well known enough to the point that
Kirkman would have been shutting himself
out that much he does reference himself
a lot though so who knows mate I'm just
saying I can't remember like I can't
remember what happened last week mate
don't don't ask me about 2004 anyway in
these other realities Mark also comes
across an animated serieses Batman and
it really could be a good point to
reference other things angstrom just
keeps wearing him down though and it
tortes Mark knowing that he's helpless
to save his mother and brother in the
end though he manages to break out and
Mark just whs on him angstrom takes him
to a post-apocalyptic reality which is
where he ends up smashing his face like
get a like button now this could be the
reality that he used to break the MERS
out in episode one and this would help
to explain how mock gets home believing
that he was the stronger one mock has to
live with the guilty feels over
apparently kill him and it's once more
him wrestling with over whether he's
becoming his father on top of this man
stuck out in this reality with no way
home get it cuz he's going into other
universes and mean Spider-Man is like a
bit like no way home at this point other
versions of the Guardians arrive and we
learn that they've been looking for him
for decades they're able to send him
back to his own time but in that branch
of reality Mark ended up disappearing
during the fight and as they've spent
several years trying to track him down I
kind of feel like they might be able to
use them all As in some way to pinpoint
that Dimension and potentially go back
there which is how they'll explain that
they were able to track him down either
way the E we mete here is over the moon
to see him again but sadly she's
devastated that they never got their
time together she even professes her
love for Mark and he ends up returning
home now knowing how she feels about him
duud to his dad not being around Mark
ends up going to Art to ask for advice
and the pair then talk things through
with Marx still deciding to stay with
Amber we'll see how long that lasts mate
but I think that that's a Poss ability
of where things could be going now this
is also an important conversation
because it's when Mark brings up his
dad's books that was sort of a
cliffhanger for the first part of the
season with Nolan saying my
books read my books Mark guessing that R
ended up picking these up and Mark ends
up reading through them which is when he
discovers their secrets Nolan had
written these quote unquote science
fiction novels as a way to basically
Chronicle chapters of his life with them
actually being biography instead of Tall
Tales Mark realizes his dad's outlined a
way to defeat the vites with his bucks
offering the key to their destruction
now I kind of feel like those are the
main plot lines we're going to get in
Season 2 and I think that Nolan will
probably be out of it for now you may
get a post CR scene with him or
something but I I feel like he he'll be
gone off the board until the events of
season 3 obviously let me know if you
agree or not as he is the most popular
character let's be honest H but I think
other elements will be pulled in on the
whole but that that's kind of where I'm
leaning with things in terms of the main
plot either way please drop a like on
the video and if you want to support the
channel as a member of the spoiler
Society then please click the join
button you'll get early access to videos
every week and it goes such a long way
to helping us out we really really
appreciate it now if you want to get
some heavy spoilers merch we also got
our t-shirt line located below the video
that will let you pick up all kinds of
tops like our Theory time one house of
dragon stuff Marvel te's and a lot more
we drop new designs on there all the
time too so definitely keep I out for
them and huge thank you for supporting
now if you want some else to watch then
make sure you check out our season 2
episode 4 breakdown which will be linked
on screen right now you want to know
what happens in the comics with all this
stuff that's in the comics you want to
know that well you come to the right
place mate we've got all that for you so
thanks for clicking that which I know I
know you're going to do now after that
amazing sales pitch I'll see you over
there H and thank you for all your time
on this I've been your host Paul you
enjoy the rest of your week mate and
take care of yourself peace